hey david how much longer do you think
we're going to
need coronavirus stimulus bills so
there's two questions here how much
longer will we need them
and is there really a shot at getting
another one i've said before
this third coronavirus stimulus
i think in all likelihood is going to be
the last now i know that there are lots
of folks who have put out
very good proposals sort of pandemic
basic income versions of universal basic
income continue doing
uh two thousand bucks a month or a
thousand bucks a month or whatever the
case may be
until certain economic metrics have been
met others are into that idea but only
on a means-tested basis
i think it's all going to be moot i
believe that the political appetite for
corona these big coronavirus stimulus
packages
maybe i'm wrong i think this is the last
one i don't think there's going to be a
fourth one
but that wasn't really the question the
question was how how much longer do you
think the
economy and americans will need stimulus
i think
the the reality is that soon
um the case for acute covet stimulus
as an umbrella if we continue
vaccinating
if the variants don't completely upend
what we're trying to do and the
reductions that we're seeing my hope is
that
we will have a dramatically recovered
economy
probably by the beginning of the fourth
quarter of this year
although some industries are going to
need help for longer
what i think is missing in this question
how much longer will we need
covid stimulus is that what we really
need and this has been exposed by the
pandemic
we need the systemic changes that many
social democrats like me have been
advocating for
for over a decade at this point in time
and as we pointed out
when the virus first hit systems we
think are robust
are actually really fragile remember
what happened
with food supply and toilet paper just
an example of systems we think very
little about day to day
but as soon as you have a shock to the
system it becomes extraordinarily
fragile
some of these examples of fragility
include significant
income inequality when a pandemic hits
income inequality in this case became
dramatically exacerbated so when you
start with an unequal situation you have
a massive
collapse of the economy and then you get
a k-shaped recovery where the very rich
do really really well
and a lot of people do not that is an
example of something
where a more robust system of social
safety nets
among many other changes and policies
we've been talking about
health care not being linked to
employment and so many other things
living wage all these different things
they make the system less fragile to
begin with and so
i think that there's a debate to be had
as to should there be a fourth
coronavirus stimulus would there be an
appetite for something else in may
or in june or whatever the case may be
maybe they can get it done maybe they
can't
much less covet stimulus would have been
needed obviously if trump had better
handled the virus
and not as many jobs had been lost and
all of that but just as importantly
if the systemic changes i've been
talking about for a decade
were in place things wouldn't have
gotten nearly as bad as they got
if people had health care not connected
to work if social safety nets were more
robust
if everybody earned a living wage right
we we really need
change for everyone systemically
rather than i would argue another bill
that helps
some people even if it's most if the
current recovery continues
job creation reduction in unemployment
rate
reductions and deaths reductions in
hospitalizations
uh we're seeing a lot of jobs come back
as part time which hopefully will become
full time we talked about the jobs
report
from february at the beginning of the
week and um
it's you know this this third stimulus
makes sense economically and politically
joe biden
ran on it promised it many senate
democrat democratic candidates
also ran on it um it would be a major
failure not to have done it we're not at
a point where we can say we don't need
that
my hope is that in three to four months
we'll be at a point
where we'll be able to say we need very
targeted stimulus for people in
particular situations
but now it's time to fix the systems
and do the real infrastructure spending
so that the next pandemic
isn't as big as a disaster at this one
right now it's too early
virus is still causing a lot of damage a
lot of people are still
unemployed will be unemployed for the
foreseeable future we're 9 million
jobs short of where we were before the
pandemic so
you give people checks you provide a
buffer you enhance unemployment child
tax credits all these things
eventually if anything good comes from
this virus in the united states
it would be realizing how far behind we
are so many other rich countries
when it comes to social safety nets and
dampening the blow of something like
this to begin with
i'm probably being naively optimistic
given some of the people that are
representing us in the house and senate
right now
and that actually relates to the next
question we're going to talk about
one of our sponsors is monk pack
it's tough to get excited about most
granola bars
they have a lot of carbs they don't
taste that great
they don't really satisfy your cravings
but monk pack has something totally
different monk pack
keto granola bars are sweet and
delicious
with a soft and chewy texture
only 140 calories one gram of sugar
and only two to three net carbs which
make them work
perfectly for the keto or low carb
lifestyles
they come in excellent flavors like
coconut cocoa chip
honey nut blueberry almond vanilla
that's my new favorite
i love these because you can just grab
them anytime maybe it's a quick
breakfast an afternoon snack when you're
busy
forget the dry bland granola bars you've
had in the past
try out monk pack keto granola bars
if you don't love them like i do they'll
give you all of your money back
you'll get twenty percent off when you
go to monkpack.com and use the coupon
code
pacman the link is underneath this video